la mondialisation peut-elle sauver le
monde
là vous êtes en train de vous demander
ce que j'ai pu boire ou fumer avant de
vous rejoindre parce que c'est vrai que
la mondialisation a somme toute pas
vraiment la cote en la mondialisation
elle facilite la propagation des
épidémies elle accélère le changement
climatique elle amplifie les inégalités
et puis au fond est-ce que ce monde a
vraiment besoin d'être sauvé
si on y regarde bien l'espérance de vie
était de 49 ans en 1950 elle est de 73
ans aujourd'hui partout dans le monde
la mortalité infantile a été divisée par
deux en 30 ans
800 millions de personnes sont sorties
de la très grande pauvreté également en
30 ans alors vous allez me dire oui
normal c'est la Chine c'est la Chine et
l'essor économique de la Chine c'est
vrai mais ça n'est pas que la Chine dans
un tas de pays dans le monde jusque là
condamné au sous-développement
la croissance économique et la
mondialisation ont permis à une partie
de la population de sortir de ce qu'on
appelle l'extrême pauvreté alors ils
sont pas devenus riches vous en
conviendrez mais concrètement ça veut
dire quoi et bien ça veut dire que dans
des quartiers à Dakar ou à Niamey dans
des bidons villes à nous délits des
favelas au Brésil et bien des familles
ont pu s'offrir un téléviseur écran plat
une machine à laver le linge et
convenons une machine à laver linge ça
change la vie surtout pour les femmes
qui sont encore majoritairement à la
manœuvre sur ce type d'activité
et pourtant au moment où je vous parle
une personne sur dix sur cette planète
ne s'alimente pas comme elles le
voudrait par manque d'accès à
l'alimentation ou parce qu'avec
l'inflation les prix ont fortement
augmenté et en même temps chez nous en
France
un tiers de notre alimentation
et jeter à la poubelle parce que périmée
le changement climatique s'accélère je
ne vous apprends rien les incendies se
multiplient partout dans le monde
en Australie au Canada aux États-Unis
les inondations au Pakistan l'an passé
en 2022 on dévasté 10% du territoire de
ce pays affecté 33 millions d'individus
sans parler de toutes les écoles les
hôpitaux les infrastructures les
cultures détruites
je pourrais rajouter à cette liste des
mauvaises nouvelles les guerres la
menace nucléaire agitée par la Russie ou
la Corée du Nord les dettes qui
s'accumulent et qui mettent des états
comme des individus dans des situations
extrêmement précaires les tensions
géopolitiques qui se multiplient les
inégalités qui se creusent bon je vais
peut-être arrêter là la liste des
mauvaises nouvelles mais convenons il y
a peut-être quelque chose à sauver dans
ce monde
ce que vous êtes en train de vous
demander c'est oui effectivement mais
est-ce que la mondialisation qui est au
fond l'une des causes aussi de tous ces
phénomènes peuvent vraiment sauver le
monde alors avant de répondre à cette
question je vous propose de réfléchir à
ce que c'est que cette mondialisation
si je vous posais la question à chacun
d'entre vous
chante chacun me donnerait une réponse
différente
certains me diraient la mondialisation
c'est la multiplication des échanges
commerciaux
d'autres me parleraient des études que
leurs enfants ont pu faire à l'étranger
ou de la possibilité qu'il leur a été
offertes de venir travailler en France
ou d'aller travailler à l'étranger
la mondialisation c'est pour chacun
d'entre nous de nouvelles possibilités
de consommation c'est la possibilité de
manger des tomates et des haricots verts
tout au long de l'année c'est aussi des
prix qui baissent et donc la possibilité
d'acheter plus plus de vêtements plus
d'équipements ménagers plus
d'électronique de changer notre
téléphone portable tous les deux ans par
exemple
cette mondialisation tout ça c'est la
mondialisation c'est aussi Internet et
la possibilité qui nous est offertes de
communiquer aujourd'hui avec qui que ce
soit qu'il soit en face de moi ou qu'il
soit à l'autre bout de la planète
grâce à internet et les réseaux sociaux
même la culture et nos loisirs ont été
changés par cette mondialisation
quand j'étais petite en France nous
avions trois chaînes de télévision
aujourd'hui nous regardons tous partout
dans le monde sur les mêmes plateformes
de streaming les mêmes séries et les
succès ils viennent de Corée du Sud
d'Espagne ou même de France alors tout
ceci est très récent en réalité mais si
on réfléchit à ce que ça nous dit ça
nous dit que la mondialisation c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement ancien et
c'est quelque chose qui qui est dans
notre nature humaine c'est la curiosité
c'est cette envie que nous avons tous de
savoir ce qu'il y a après la mère ce qui
a derrière la colline ou la montagne
sauf que cette curiosité elle se heurte
aussi à une note de nos caractéristiques
notre peur de l'inconnu et face à cette
peur de l'inconnu on a tous envie de
contrôler de tout contrôler
et parfois de dominer
et au fond cette mondialisation qui est
une ouverture elle a rythmé l'évolution
de nos sociétés l'évolution de notre
civilisation les grandes découvertes les
innovations technologiques elles sont
liées à cette curiosité à cette envie de
comprendre à cette envie d'aller plus
loin
mais vous noterez que si ces
mondialisations ont marqué toute notre
histoire et tout le développement de
notre humanité elles n'ont pas été
linéaires et continue dans le temps
et toutes les périodes où nous avons
vécu un arrêt de la mondialisation un
arrêt de cette volonté de découvrir de
cette curiosité de cette ouverture
ont été un signe que ça n'allait pas
très bien je pourrais citer des tas
d'exemples je vais juste prendre la
crise de 1929 qui a eu pour conséquence
immédiate le protectionnisme et le repli
sur soi et puis pour conséquence un
petit peu plus lointaine ou seconde
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et tout ce
qui s'en est suivi
les conséquences de ce repli ont été
tellement énormes qu'au sortir de cette
seconde guerre mondiale nos chefs
d'états ont absolument voulu éviter
voulu réouvrir un nouveau
donc on le voit la mondialisation c'est
quelque chose que nous portons en nous
et chaque étape dans notre histoire de
mondialisation a été très particulière
la mondialisation que nous vivons depuis
30 ans elle est concomitante à la fin de
la guerre froide la fin de la guerre
froide c'est quoi et bien c'est la fin
d'un affrontement entre deux systèmes
politiques mais aussi deux systèmes
économiques le socialisme et le
capitalisme et la conclusion qu'on en
tire au tout début des années 90 c'est
qu'au fond
le système capitaliste a vaincu le
socialisme par chaos fin de l'histoire
c'est-à-dire
qu'au fond on a la certitude à ce moment
là de la suprémarie du marché de fait
que la concurrence et le meilleur moyen
d'accumuler les richesses et donc
paruissellement de profiter à tous
et les états vont en tirer toutes les
conclusions qui s'imposent à ce
moment-là
on va réduire autant que faire ce peu
toutes les règles qui viennent entraver
le commerce mondial ça va être d'une
efficacité absolue puisque entre 1990 et
demi les échanges commerciaux doublés
entre 2000 et 2020 ils vont doubler à
nouveau et vous constaterez que même la
Chine pourtant pas capitaliste au début
des années 90 va adopter les mêmes
principes le revenu par habitant au
niveau mondial va tripler donc une
certaine efficacité de cette
mondialisation et de chez soi mais en
même temps en même temps
et bien le paysan africain ne va plus
pouvoir vivre dans ce monde là de la
production de café ou de volaille
pourquoi parce que le poulet venu
d'Europe coûte bien moins cher sur le
marché local
des centaines de milliers de personnes
d'ouvriers dans les usines dans les pays
les plus développés vont se retrouver au
chômage du jour au lendemain parce que
leur entreprise a décidé de délocaliser
dans des pays où la main d'oeuvre est
bien moins chère
va arriver une pandémie et là on va se
rendre compte qu'on est même pas capable
d'équiper nos soignants de blues et de
masques qui les protégeront pour nous
soigner pourquoi parce qu'on sait plus
les produire d'une part et ensuite parce
que la Chine s'est confinée avant nous
et que peut plus nous approvisionner
est-ce qu'on veut vraiment continuer
comme ça certainement pas mais pour
autant est-ce que le repli sur soi est
la solution bah là non plus là non plus
ce serait un non-sens au moment où les
défis qui nous sont posés sont des défis
qui ne peuvent être relevés que tous
ensemble prenez le changement climatique
et la transition énergétique nous avons
besoin de nous approvisionnements de
cobalt et de lithium de pays qui les
extraits
donc nous ne pouvons pas continuer comme
ça il nous faut inventer une nouvelle
mondialisation
or ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est
que on a une tendance à repli sur soi
vous avez face à cette complexité à
cette géopolitique des tas d'entreprises
aujourd'hui cherchent à sécuriser leur
chaîne de valeur leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement en relocalisant sur
des territoires plus sûrs c'est la
mondialisation entre amis comme si tous
les autres étaient devenus des ennemis
le frenchoring en anglais
si il faut inventer une nouvelle
mondialisation il faut inventer cette
mondialisation responsable solidaire
mais aussi inclusive responsable parce
que de toute façon face au changement
climatiques faut que nos modes de vie
deviennent plus sobre
solidaires parce que on voit bien
aujourd'hui le moindre problème à un
endroit de la planète a des conséquences
sur nous tous
la solidarité c'est pas un rêve naïve
dans ce contexte c'est un investissement
hautement rentable puis je me permets
une petite parenthèse n'oublions pas que
ce qui subissent aujourd'hui le plus
durement le changement climatique n'en
sont pas les principaux responsables
donc là il n'est plus question de
solidarité les questions de justice
inclusive enfin parce que si nous
arrivions à sauver le monde ce que je
nous souhaite tous
est-ce que nous pourrions nous
satisfaire de voir en faire encore des
enfants qui meurent de faim clairement
pas alors j'ai une bonne nouvelle cette
mondialisation elle est en train de se
dessiner sous nos yeux regardez cette
ONG colombienne il y a quelques semaines
qui a porté plainte contre trois grandes
banques parce qu'elles financent une
entreprise d'extraction minière qui
vitrait semblablement ne pratique pas
l'extraction minière totalement dans les
règles
en fait c'est toute une société civile
qui s'est réveillée il y a quelques
années et qui se bat au niveau mondial
grâce aux réseaux sociaux
pour les mêmes causes en réalité la
lutte contre la corruption une plus
grande responsabilité des entreprises
la lutte contre le changement climatique
contre les inégalités contre la pauvreté
regardez aussi tous ces pays aujourd'hui
qui veulent participer plus largement
aux affaires du monde c'est le président
Lula qui propose un plan pour la paix
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie c'est loin
l'Ukraine vue du Brésil c'est également
la Chine qui cherche à rapprocher l'Iran
et l'Arabie Saoudite pour enfin
stabiliser le Moyen-Orient
vous voyez
tout ça va complètement dans le bon sens
dans le sens d'une ouverture dans le
sens d'une nouvelle mondialisation une
mondialisation qui serait encore une
fois responsable solidaire et inclusif
vous la voulez cette mondialisation
moi aussi
il y a plus qu'à
merci
[Applaudissements]